the terror which would not end for
another 28 years if it ever did end
began so far as I know or can tell with
a boat made from a sheet of newspapers
floating down a gutter swollen with rain
this is how Stephen King begins it his
22nd novel published in 1986 it's a
passage that really exemplifies what
King does best in so engrossing you in
the horrific and unknown and it's this
unique ability that has made him one of
the best-selling writers of our time
selling over three hundred and fifty
million copies worldwide and earning him
the distinguished title of master of
horror yet despite his success and
popularity King is still a difficult
writer to discuss among the literary
circle once described by the New York
Times as a writer of fairly engaging and
preposterous claptrap there has been a
long-standing discussion on whether
Kings works are really literature or
just glorified pulp nonetheless King has
managed to create some of the most
iconic and haunting stories ever to come
out of the genre which raises the
question how does he do it
[Music]
like any writer king isn't shy to share
his sources of inspiration most notably
writers like Richard Matheson of I am
Legend and Bram Stoker of the now
classic Dracula but perhaps the writer
that most closely resembles his style is
HP Lovecraft one of the most influential
writers of the horror genre he
single-handedly created a whole new
sub-genre that is now more commonly
known as cosmic horror in which unknown
cosmic entities and phenomena beyond our
understanding
often portrayed as ancient mythical
monsters became the subject of horror
but the monsters of Lovecraft were never
really monsters instead there were
metaphors that symbolized Lovecraft's
deep fear of the rapid technological and
scientific advancements in the early
20th century the helplessness he felt
towards the changes around him reflected
in the hopeless struggle of people
against forces that are far beyond their
control
Lovecraft believed that people's
inability to truly understand the
reality was the most merciful thing in
the world and that doing so would be
enough to drive anyone to insanity in
many ways this is the same kind of
horror that king taps into whether it's
vampires a haunted hotel or a rabid dog
the subjects of kings horror all
represent our fear for something else
more specifically the societal fears of
the American people in Danse Macabre
Kings study of the horror genre he
explains that there are two different
kinds of horror
the first is horror that plays on our
phobic pressure points these are fears
based on our individual phobias like the
fear of spiders or ghosts something that
a lot of recent horror movies have based
themselves on but these Horrors also
have a clear limit as they target a very
specific group of people with that
specific phobia which is why more
effective and successful works of [ __ ]
play with what's known as national
pressure points these are political
societal and psychological fears that
are
by a wider spectrum of people like in
the works of Lovecraft and King are
represented by the abnormal and the
supernatural
it's what King excels at living through
some of the most tumultuous periods in
American history his debut novel carry
on a surface a book about a girl with
telekinetic powers is really a story
about the suppression of female
sexuality in the 60s published just six
years after the famous Miss America
protest in 1968 and in the shining a
book about a family stranded in a
haunted hotel King picks apart the
concept of patriarchy that is deeply
rooted into the American culture to
discuss the cyclical nature of parental
legacy sometimes it's more personal two
of his most famous works misery and Cujo
deal with addiction and the lack of
self-control and companies and were
written by King during his own struggle
with drugs and alcohol
like Lovecraft the horrors that King
portrays are self reflective and
grounded in our reality which in turn
makes the horror feel that much more
real their representations of American
fear things that threaten the very
foundation of the society we live in and
just like Lovecraft it's reality that
terrifies King as he once put it it
isn't the physical or mental
abnormalities that really horrify us but
the lack of order in our reality they
represent so how does King put this on
paper the first thing to note is that
situation comes first Kings books are
often based on situations rather than
intricate plots every single one of his
works is based on a series of what-if
scenarios like what if an ancient cosmic
evil in the shape of a clown terrorized
a small town in Maine then he drops a
group of well fleshed out characters
right into the heart of the situation
but it's not to help them work their way
free
but to simply watch what happens and
it's this spontaneity that allows for
some of the most unexpected and shocking
moments in Kings stories and it's
impossible to talk about Stephen King
without talking about suspense as he
said himself well if you ask the
ordinary run-of-the-mill reader if there
is such a guy or such a gal I guess that
I write horror novels I think that what
I actually write are suspense novels
another master of suspense Alfred
Hitchcock once that suspense is the most
powerful means of holding on to the
viewers attention and so what King also
excels grabbing your attention and
keeping it on something horrific
so you're unable to turn away and he
accomplishes this by applying three of
the most basic literary devices the
first step is for shattering both his
books and adaptations are riddled with
minds and moments that hint at what's to
come Georgie
be careful this is why Kings stories
have an overarching sense of doom and
dread
unlike most horror novels and films it's
not the uncertainty of danger that has
you on edge but exactly when that danger
will finally happen then the next step
is call back where King racks up the
suspense by continuously reminding the
audience that the danger is lurking and
oftentimes it takes a while for the
danger to actually show its face and
then finally the payoff in which the
suspense we've been building towards
reaches its peak we finally face the
danger we've been waiting for and it's
at this final moment that King scares us
and you can very well see this
throughout King's career even in the
passage that started this video with
just one line foreshadowing the terror
to come they call back to the longevity
of said terror and finally the payoff to
the very thing that started it all
analyzing the works of Stephen King is a
great opportunity to understand what
really scares us at the end of the day
his works are prime examples that show
us that our object of fear very much
exists in our own reality sometimes it's
not the monsters or ghosts that scare us
but the horrors of everyday life lurking
in the corners waiting to strike and
it's this horror that King knows and
understands perhaps better than anyone
and if that's not enough to make him the
master of horror it would be hard to
find someone else that deserves it more
you
[Music]